Speaker 1: So the more.
Speaker 2: We learn about Ron DeSantis, Martha's
Vineyard immigrant stunt, the more we realize it
was certainly immoral, it was certainly unethical.
It was certainly a waste of Florida taxpayer money
to send immigrants that were in Texas to an island
off the coast of Massachusetts. Those things we
all know. We know that it was dishonest because
we have now learned that the immigrants were
indeed enticed with false promises of all sorts
of goodies at the end of the rainbow, for lack
of a better term. But now there's a new question,
and as often is the case with the very people who
claim that they are all about law enforcement and
due process and doing everything correctly and law
and order or line auto. As Donald Trump has said
before, it may not have been legal either. And
there is a very, very good article in NPR about
this on NPR.org by Valerie Crowder. And I'm going
to tell you some of the key points here that are
now in question about whether this was legal or
could it have been illegal human trafficking. So
the first aspect to this is that Ron DeSantis
described the flights on which the immigrants
were taken to Martha's Vineyard as voluntary when
he was speaking at a press conference on Friday.
It appears that that was a lie. Immigration law
experts say that actually what happened was the
trafficking of migrants. When you lie to people
to induce them to come somewhere to the U.S. or
whatever, in order for something that is not true,
you are participating in what is functionally
speaking the same type of trafficking where young
girls are tricked into going wherever with the
promises of whatever it is they're promised, and
then they're actually forced into prostitution. As
an example, the dynamic is exactly the same. And
we've now learned that these immigrants were told,
you're going to be flown to Boston. They
weren't. They were flown to Martha's Vineyard.
You'll get expedited work papers, which was not
actually what was waiting for them in Martha's
Vineyard. And instead what happened was churches
and shelters and aid groups, as NPR writes,
did the best to accommodate them on an island
with an extraordinarily low population and very
limited resources. Now then we heard from
a Tallahassee based immigration attorney,
Elizabeth Ricci, also quoted in this NPR article
who says There is a good faith argument to be made
that when you lure migrants onto planes with false
promises of jobs, you are making them victims of
fraudulent human trafficking. Think of that. That
is what the governor of Florida has potentially
engaged in here. They were told, oh, you might.
You're going to get this. You're going to get
that. Now, here's the unbelievable part. If indeed
these individuals are determined to have been the
victims of fraud and human trafficking, they could
automatically qualify for visas here in the United
States. What Ron DeSantis may have illegally
done could. We don't know yet actually genuinely
expedite these individuals to legal status
here in the United States. He explained, quote,
An enticement like that, regardless of whether
you sign a waiver, is fraud. And that's part of
the definition of human trafficking. I think that
everybody on those planes has a case to legalize
as a direct result of being transported by the
governor. Republicans will do illegal things,
and if they get arrested or prosecuted, they
will claim they are merely political prisoners,
that they're being treated unfairly. This is
what happened after the January six riots,
the January 6th rioters. And there were hundreds
of them. I think the numbers up to seven or 800,
although it may even be over a thousand. They
were acting criminally. And then once the law
caught up with them, the claims started to be made
of, well, they're not being given the right food
in jail. They're being held unfairly in jail.
Pretrial detention is unfair. These are victims
of politics. They're being punished because of
their opinion about an election. This is the move.
So without a doubt, if the law starts to catch up
to dissent, this and whoever else for this absurd
stunt, mark my words and you know this, I don't
have to convince you of this. They will claim
they are actually the victims, the people who did
this, who were just trying to prove a point. Now,
one other thing. There are right wingers who
think they're being really slick by saying
something like the following. And there's
versions of this floating around. You know,
all you northern liberals talk about Texas and
Florida and Arizona should just accept hundreds
of thousands of migrants. And it's very easy
to say from Vermont or from Massachusetts or
whatever. But as soon as 50 people get to Martha's
Vineyard, they are immediately deported out.
Multiple things going on here. First of all, it's
not a deportation when you're just flown from one
state to another. That's number one. Number
two, the intent of these immigrants was not
to be in Martha's Vineyard. Martha's Vineyard is
tiny. There is very few jobs. It's a very small
economy and it's a very seasonal economy because
of tourism. And we're heading into fall and then
winter, which is low season. And Martha's
Vineyard, there is not the real opportunity
for any jobs there. There's extraordinarily
limited housing, etc.. So there's really not
the hypocrisy that the right wants to point
out. Furthermore, they were lied to in so
getting to Martha's Vineyard and as I mentioned,
it was not their intent. So this this hypocrisy
that the right is trying to expose in talking
about the Martha's Vineyard thing, it's a joke.
And we shouldn't allow them to turn that around
because it just doesn't make any sense whatsoever